hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and kiss him and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People doesn't get any more fascinating
than the guests will have for you today
without much further Ado she's the
journalist behind the lockdown files
Isabel okay welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me and you've had a
very busy week so we appreciate you
coming and sitting down for 45 minutes
so let's chat and then answering some
questions from our audience really
appreciate it you know it's funny
because I was talking to a friend of
mine last night we were what's happening
back and forth and dangerous thing to do
especially when I'm around well that's
that's and and that was basically how
the conversation ended up after a while
we kind of read back our slightly spicy
messages and we were like well let's
make sure whoever writes ghost writes
our next book is not Isabella and the
point I'm making is you have put
you know something on the line there in
order to get this story out so what was
it about the messages that you saw with
Matt Hancock the former Health secretary
that made you think you know what this
is worth it well you're absolutely right
I mean of course I've put something on
the line I've put a lot on the line
actually I mean there's been a lot of
flack flying the reality is if you
detonate a nuclear bomb there's going to
be some radiation and most likely quite
a bit of it is going to blow in your
direction if we're talking about the
worlds of politics so that I knew that
this would be pretty explosive
um I knew that there would be a price to
pay for me
um there are different bits of that
price to pay there's a there's a legal
risk that I've taken um after all I did
reach a confidentiality undertaking
that's not something I I take lightly or
do flippantly there's also the risk
associated with people you know feeling
that I probably I'm not going to be the
most trustworthy person to write write
their books that's that's obviously
something that I have to take into
account
but above all of that is what I felt was
the overwhelming public interest in the
content of this material
um and you know in the end uh I'm was
willing and am willing to take a knock
to my reputation to have people
disparaging me to have people say that I
to to impugn my motives which has been
plenty of in order to get this material
out there because what we see here is
the real time
detail of who was saying what and when
around the most momentous decisions
decisions that affected the lives of
every single person in this country and
similar decisions were being taken all
over the world as countries locked down
so really the UK as a result of these
WhatsApp files as Fraser Nelson has said
is the first country to have kind of
drawn back the curtain on what was
really going on and what have we seen as
well because look Francis and I both not
happy about lockdowns we supported the
first one because we were told it's
going to be a couple of weeks and blah
blah blah okay let's go along with it
and before we know it we're like two
years into a lockdown and yeah right
however there's a lot of people who
might look at the things that have come
out as a result of your Revelations and
kind of go well okay look the fact that
kids were forced to wear masks because
Boris couldn't be bothered to have an
argument with Nicola yeah that's a bit
that's a lot bad
and most of the rest of it isn't it just
government incompetence politicians
making stupid jokes the kinds of you
that you and I would make in a WhatsApp
group so what what have you revealed
exactly that people should care about if
they currently done yeah that's funny
you know I find this this question has
come up quite a lot and I'm kind of left
wondering what more do you want guys
blood you know what is it that you might
have been expecting to find there I feel
that people maybe hope that there might
be some kind of gigantic conspiracy you
know that there's a lot of people yeah
you know that we might reveal that you
know there was a secret plan to kind of
kill off the elderly or there was some
kind of Bill Gates thing to inject
everybody with microchips Hancock did
actually joke about that but it was a
very definitely a joke obviously
um and you know I feel that there were a
lot of people hoping
um that what was going on during this
time was something totally extraordinary
and unexpected and in reality what was
going on was the very exaggerated
everyday business of government which is
full of [__] up and far more [__] up
than conspiracy really but what have we
learned well we can point to any number
of a kind of specific Revelations which
I actually think are very important you
know the over the weekend the telegraph
published details of messages from Matt
Hancock between him and his political
Aid in which they discussed and I quote
deploying the variant to and I quote
frighten the pants off people now this
is an Insight provides us with an
extraordinary insight into the mindset
of a very very tiny group of people who
had seized an unprecedented level of
power so what you see here in a sense is
a kind of
um insight into the psychology of what
happens when a small group of people
take power which they did They seized
effectively an unprecedented level of
control over our everyday lives and they
they essentially did so in a
pseudo-democratic fashion that we can
discuss quite how Democratic it really
was but they used emergency legislation
to do that and what did they then do
with that power and we've had since
politicians coming out Jacob we smog
yesterday one of our who was a cabinet
minister at the time saying actually you
know I was in the cabinet at the time I
didn't know about a lot of this stuff
that was going on evidence that
influence critical decisions because it
was all concentrated in the hands of
four people effectively the Prime
Minister the chancellor at the time
Richard sunac Michael Gove who's kept
very much in the shadows and I always
thought he was up to all forms of no
good you know when a politician of that
level of influence is very quiet it's a
bit like when kids disappear and you
know they're somewhere upstairs and you
kind of know that they definitely got
your makeup back you know they're busy
smearing it all over everywhere
um so Michael Gove plays a pivotal part
in all of this and Matt Hancock himself
and those four people just were were in
an extraordinary position of power and
responsibility by the way and I think we
can have a lot of sympathy
um for the people on Whose shoulders all
of this rested you know he said
um we were talking earlier about whether
it was the right thing to lock down
first time around I mean absolutely you
know I never felt that that was
unreasonable you know in the face of an
unprecedented threat for me I think
there are very very serious question
marks over whether we needed to do so
repeatedly for the best part of off and
on two years in a way that had we now
know devastating collateral damage on
our economy but much more importantly on
people's Health in in other respects and
on our children it's about now I'm
someone who was I was in favor of the
first lockdown like Constantine but the
more I saw this past and repeats itself
the more I realized where we were going
to end up particularly financially
however I have come to accept
begrudgingly that I'm in the minority
and there's a lot of government
ministers who would say well look you
may think this way I think this way but
the reality is 65 of the public
according to recent polls don't think
that way oh yeah I find that really
interesting actually
it's just really weird I've kind of come
to the conclusion that people like being
told what to do
um you know it's why a lot of people
just keep going back to prison because
presumably in prison you don't have to
actually decide anything you know you've
got your regime you've got your routine
you're told when to get up you're told
when to exercise you're told when to go
to bed you've fed something you know
you've got all your basic facilities
there and that's it that's the end of
your responsibility I think some people
perhaps quite like that abrogation of
responsibility for their own existence I
find it pretty warped personally I think
but maybe maybe some people's lives are
not quite as richly rewarding as as our
own and so I don't know maybe they felt
less of a loss at being bossed around in
that way I mean part of it was also
let's be fair that let's be fair that
the government put made them absolutely
terrified with their propaganda and gave
them money yeah
agree with that I mean you know focus
groups and polling will show
um that terrified people are grateful if
you protect them so if you've then put
vast resources into terrifying a
population it should be no surprise that
that terrified population thanks you for
looking after them as you present it to
them at the time and that Fear Factor
has had a long hangover hasn't it I mean
I still see people walking outside with
masks on and
maybe it's a bad reflection on me
there's something inside me that just
really kind of rails against that I feel
sorry for them
um but I also can't understand why they
think that that's going to make any
difference to their existence
um and you know one of the uh one of the
things that spurred me on on this
project is because there's of course
been a lot of criticism and there always
is I work you know in the intersection
of politics and media I'm not a neutral
reporter or a neutral commentator I'm a
right of Center uh broadcaster and
commentator and that in itself attracts
quite a lot of flack but one of the
things that's really kept me going as it
were
um is the absolute flood of letters and
emails and approaches on Twitter from
ordinary people who say thank you for
exposing all of this stuff we knew we
thought this was what was going on and
now we know that our suspicions were
were Justified and you know some of the
letters I'm getting are so moving
profoundly moving in a particular the
mother of a 16 year old boy who took his
own life during lockdown I wrote about
her and him in the telegraph last
weekend and you know these um these were
very disempowered individuals it was all
very well
um for our leaders in their lovely big
houses in leafy parts of London with all
the luxuries that made lockdown at the
very worst bearable and for many better
off people really quite pleasurable it
was all very well for those people but
what about the single mom living on a
rough Council estate in bootle with a
five-year-old as this lady had who has
ADHD I'm picturing that she was in some
kind of high-rise block or something
like that anyway they have no Garden the
only place was a local play park and
That Was Then cordoned off by
overzealous Council officials as we now
know
entirely unnecessarily in my view it was
soon quite obvious that the virus wasn't
going to be transmitted in play parks
really certainly not children you know
they weren't particularly vulnerable to
it so in desperation this mother fearing
that there would be more lockdowns quite
rightly as it turned out she moved house
and took her family up to the Northeast
where she was unable to get her teenage
son into a school by then of course
homeschooling had become a lazy default
for local authorities they couldn't be
bothered to find a place for her son
this lady was not empowered she had no
agency you know if somebody
didn't find a school place for my
children I'd be creating Mary hell but
she didn't have the means to create Mary
hell and so her son was isolated and
became increasingly depressed he put on
weight because he was no longer playing
football at school and along on the
shorts and it is a very long and sorry
tale is that he hung himself one day he
took himself off saying that he was
going to go shopping getting pick up a
few things for tea and he never came
home and you know she said that he had
become so
paranoid because of the fear campaign
that he would not even open his bedroom
window for fear of the virus creeping in
and getting him well look something's
gone profoundly wrong
if children are reacting to a government
propaganda campaign in that way and you
know I am not a crier I rarely shed
tears but I genuinely was
deeply upset by her story because I know
not least in itself it is a terrible
story but because it's replicated in so
many different ways across Britain and
I'm having so many of these messages
people died and of course and and there
are many people who suffered in many
ways and this is one of the things we
talked on the show about extensively but
Isabel then this isn't to take anything
away from what you've just said because
I think it's really important but I
guess France's point is
what is there in these lockdown files
that will convince those people who
don't agree with the three of us that
they should
perhaps nothing because I think there's
something wrong with them
well good to hear you good to know you
came here
I mean look if you you can't be
persuaded by the content of these
lockdown files that this was just so
profoundly wrong what is going to
persuade you what more does it take you
know we've got tens of thousands of
children who never went back to school
we've got a broken NHS we've got an
economy in Smithereens what more
evidence do you need do you really still
think it was a good idea to shut Society
down for that long when we had a vaccine
and when the mortality rates for this
condition were not particularly high for
anybody who wasn't already above the age
of life expectancy and one of the things
that came to light in the lockdown folds
one of the things I actually I found
profoundly shocking was the quality of
evidence that was being used to the
government by the government to justify
their decisions so I think um I think
another point is as much what is not
discussed as what is and it's important
to point out and many critics quite
reasonably have done that what we have
here is only Matt bangkok's text
WhatsApp messages with the people he
chose to share with me so there may have
been conversations with other
individuals who who didn't want to share
with me and you know he was the health
secretary so his Focus was on health he
wasn't Rishi sunak whose WhatsApp with
lots of other people might have revealed
a very uh different story but at no
point in this 2.3 million word dump of
information which the telegraph's team
of eight people have brilliantly spent
the last two months picking through is
there any sense of Matt Hancock and
remember he was one of the only the four
that were taking all these critical
decisions worrying about the collateral
damage of the policies he was pursuing
or really troubling over the
um cost benefit analysis you know he was
not continually saying well hang on a
minute if we do this yes it may
ostensibly and in the short term be
deemed to be saving lives but what about
the lives further down the line and in
fact there was a minister a junior
Health Minister James Bethel
who did actually flag these things up on
a number of occasions quite interesting
he talked a lot about what was happening
for example with clinical trials you
know that they basically jutted to a
halt for anything other than covert
vaccines well that really matters you
know if we stopped investigating and
trying to find new cancer treatments new
treatments for Alzheimer's new
treatments for all the other desperately
awful diseases that ruin lives for the
best part of two years that research
stops that's a serious matter
um and to give James Bethel his Jew he
pushed on that quite repeatedly
um but Matt Hancock didn't seem to have
much interest I think he paid lip
service to to that but to be fair
probably didn't have the bandwidth for
anything more than his immediate
objective well that was one of my
principal concerns throughout the
pandemic really is I don't remember a
single time anyone standing up at a
prime minister's press conference and
saying how many people are these
policies going to kill because if you
don't know answer to that question how
can you possibly make the decision to
lock down so I think it's a really bad
look and although they've done it to me
I don't particularly want to do it to
them for journalists to criticize other
children but anyway
I think that there were a few of us on
the skeptical side
who watched those press conferences in
some despair at the lack of
um skepticism the lack of critical
um approach towards the policies that
were being unveiled you know I think
that very few journalists did anything
other than in a sense practically goad
the government on to go ever harder now
I I worked in the lobby for many years
as a Sunday Times political editor I
know the psychology of the political
press pack and I've been part of it um
and it's always to get the the kind of
more extreme and the worst story it's
not actually your agenda as a political
journalist in the lobby is not actually
producing good it's producing the best
possible story which is usually the
worst thing happening
um or trying to get resignations or
something and I'm I've been part of that
so I understand how it works you know
the the desire to get a scalp or the
desire to say more bad things are coming
and I think it warps the approach you
know it's not a it's not a trigonometry
style discussion you know looking at the
ups and downs on the one hand and on the
other it's boom boom boom and off we go
to file our copy
um and I'm not abrogating in my
responsibility for having been part of
that in the past but those journalists
did not not ask the questions that for
example Julia Hartley Brewer was asking
on talk radio day in day out you know
and she was quite a lone voice and
Isabel uh Douglas Murray made the point
when we were talking when we did an
interview with him during the pandemic
and he said part of the problem is the
fact that a lot of journalists don't
have a scientific background so they're
not able to interrogate the data
properly well then I certainly don't
have a scientific background as people
repeatedly it might remind them
and there was a lot of that wasn't there
anyone who criticized anything to do
with the response you would get a pylon
saying well you're not a doctor you're
not an epidemiologist I'm not taking any
lessons from you
you don't necessarily have to be an
epidemiologist
um to work out that shutting up a lot of
people locking them down only allowing
them out for an hour of exercise and
threatening to criminalize them for
sitting in a public park or sunbathing
has happened or going for a walk on
their own in the in the Hills is going
to have a pretty awful effect on
everybody's psychology and on the
businesses that are shut you know that
that isn't it doesn't take an expert to
work that out and if you've turned the
whole of the NHS if you've pivoted it to
being a covered emergency service then
probably other conditions are going to
suffer and Isabel we're looking at and
analyzing the decisions and the behavior
of government essentially with these
lockdown files what percentage of this
do you think are just mistakes which any
government can make particularly in that
time ranking competence and also as well
something a little bit more Sinister
which
I got a little bit of with those
messages which is a sneering contempt if
I'm honest I love the way you said
ranking competencies it just kind of
rolled off your tongue there he's been
practicing that yeah it's just a phrase
we use quite a lot yeah I'm learning how
to drive it's something many times by my
instructor
um there's a mixture of all of that
isn't there you know I've always wanted
to believe and I generally believed that
politicians start out genuinely wanting
to do good maybe that's a bit naive of
me but you know having worked around
politicians for nearly two decades you
know most some do want to change things
for the better they're coming from a
position of wanting to try and make
people's lives better and I I have no
doubt that
um that the then Health secretary met
Hancock was desperately trying to
contain the crisis in the way he saw
best fit with the evidence that he had
available at the time to begin with now
after that I think that there was some
loss of perspective
um some frankly a near complete loss of
any sense of proportionality
and you can imagine why that happened
you know if you've created the
conditions in which you are basically in
a bunker and normal life is all but
disappeared then of course judgments are
going to be warped I'm not saying I
would have done brilliantly in those
circumstances which one of us would have
it's always easier to cope from the
sidelines I'm certain I wouldn't have
done many of the things they did I mean
there are certain things that still
really Wrangle with me in particular the
then Home Secretary pretty Patel
actively encouraging
people in this country to Snoop and spy
on their neighbors and to report them
for breaches of covert restrictions I
thought that that coming from a Home
Secretary of a conservative government
was utterly unforgivable I thought that
it encouraged a grotesque culture in
this country which had real consequences
you know I had two police officers come
to my door on Easter Day 2021 you know
what a woeful use of police resources
sending two cops to check that I was
self-isolating my partner had the police
turn up twice at his property these
stories are everywhere aren't they
Rachel Johnson the prime minister's own
sister wrote for the telegraph a few
days ago about how the cops turned up at
her property you know I I just think
this is awful and generally they were
acting on tip-offs what kind of country
is this is that what kind of country any
government should be promoting um
well I I I mean you're making a lot of
good points your colleague at the
telegraph uh or temporary colleague I
should say Cheryl Jacobs yeah she wrote
a very interesting article uh recently
in which she essentially talked about
how rather than looking at this for as a
sort of the government getting more
power and getting power drunk actually
what they were responding to and that's
why I made the point about the
journalist is imagine you are Boris
Johnson I'm at Hancock and you're like
looking out at a journalist Lobby who
are all demanding harder deeper faster
lockdowns yeah and the polling all shows
I mean yeah you still believe polling
that's what the public want yeah
what are you supposed to do well
um let me provide a
um a really simple answer and it is to
provide leadership that's what you're
supposed to do you know you're not
supposed to just
respond to it being more by you you
you're there because you're a leader
you're there to do better than that and
right you're right and the most stunning
absence of leadership for me was
watching their capitulation to Nicholas
surgeon and that I think is such a I
mean it's a bit of a pointy head sort of
political
um Obsession but it is really
interesting until people are not
familiar yeah let me explain that
throughout these messages these WhatsApp
messages there is a continual
long-running anxiety about the devolved
administrations in particular what was
going on in Scotland where Nicholas
sturgeon who is a formidable politician
whatever you think of what she wants to
do which is namely break up the union
she is a very very good political
operator and she was very often one step
ahead of Downing Street and you know
very keen to be one step ahead and that
actually distorted the way they
responded because they were continually
worrying what's Nicola going to do next
how's Nicola going to exploit this is
Nicola going to leak the details of this
conversation or that conversation it has
a really kind of detrimental I think in
really negative effects on the overall
pandemic response but I think also
actually the government was quite right
to be worried about what Nicolas
sturgeon might do and I think they in
their defense they tried very hard to
work together with the devolved
administrations but in the end you know
Nicholas sturgeon and the SNP had a an
agenda of their own and what was their
agenda well her agenda is to promote the
cause of Independence she was also I'm
not saying she wasn't trying to save
lives first and foremost but she also
allied with that is what she's there to
do her core offer which is break up the
United Kingdom she's suddenly going to
forget that and Isabel but I really want
to talk about the masking situations in
schools oh yeah because they did back
down to her and the only reason they
backed down to her is because they were
scared of getting into an argument or a
fight with a Roots I mean they didn't
want you know I'm going to be
paraphrasing here because I can't
remember exactly what was said but
effective Lee Nicola sturgeon had
announced one policy which involved a
lot of mask wearing in schools
the UK government didn't really think
that there was mock to the case for that
but they also thought that maybe it
wouldn't do much harm either they didn't
really want a row or a split with
Nicholas sturgeon because if they'd gone
a different way they would have been
forced to say either she's got it wrong
or you know we're going to have to
accept that we're doing it anyway just
to avoid that kind of political spat
um and they just the path of least
resistance that's what they took the
path of least resistance I hate masks I
think that they are Insidious I think
the idea that they do know harm is is a
false one actually
um I think they do all sorts of harm I
want to be able to see people's faces
please I think that's the society that
we live in and you know if people really
want to go around with a piece of grubby
cloth over their face which does very
very little if it's unless it's a kind
of medical grade thing then perhaps in a
free and liberal Society we should let
them do so just so that we let people go
around with very flimsy clothes on or
whatever else they may want to wear you
know
that could be your next episode where we
lose all of our subscribers so so look
if they if people want to wear well I I
don't like it but you know maybe that's
up to them but to say that there's no
harm in forcing children to do so I
think it's just it's just untrue you
know my son was made to wear masks you
know like every other child is a
teenager at the time and there's
pictures of him School photograph we've
all got a mask on it's grotesque and it
made no practical sense because you know
a former guest I've asked Catherine
bubble Singh who runs a school she was
like I love Catherine we all do of
course she's brilliant but she was like
have you met kids
you think you're going to force
teenagers to wear masks all day in the
classroom that is not how this is going
to go down and she's a strictness you
know so it just it seemed impractical
Isabel I want to move on slightly
somewhat to the covered inquiry yes
that's really important well it is
really important and I have to say
father it should be well why because
until the the revelations that you've
been uh at the head of with this I have
to say I think the consensus among
people who think like us has been yeah
they're not it's going to take bloody
ages it's not going to find anything
it's going to be I mean it's going to be
like no one knows who killed JFK no one
knows what happened with Iraq we're not
we're not going to find anything now was
that also your view and is that part of
the rationale for releasing these this
is WhatsApp if not the Key Driving Force
for doing this because of course if the
covert inquiry was about to wrap up or
if it could realistically be expected to
conclude for example by the end of this
year or even let's say by the end of
next year if we could have confidence in
the faith that that is going to happen
then there would have been a much
greater ethical dilemma over whether or
not to release these messages because it
could argue of be arguably have been
much more difficult to defend the public
interest and doing so if they were all
going to be examined along with all the
other messages and evidence that needs
to be taken into account by a judge in
an objective you know proper fashion
um then that would perhaps be best left
to that process the problem is that the
covert inquiry has an insanely expansive
remit I've read it I'm amazed that very
few journalists have actually bothered
to do this but if you actually sit and
read the remit you know I could say that
it would take at least a year to cover
each area
um there's about 30 areas I mean this
poor judge is being asked to cover every
single aspect of the inquiry and and
some should also be in there if you're
going to go for everything then also
there should be a more areas covered I
think the only way to manage this is to
pair it right back in the way that the
swedes did they produced they they got
their inquiry underway quickly they've
already produced the report they did it
efficiently they didn't try to do
everything they paired it back to the
key lessons to be learned and that's
what we should do
um and you know if that were to happen
then then I probably wouldn't have done
what I've done here and put these
messages in the public domain but I have
no confidence in the time frame for that
process there's no deadline by the way
nobody should be deceived about this
there is no deadline well it sounds then
pretty much like unless more stuff comes
out of then unless more people yeah
because it does well quite because
um I I just don't think we're going to
get to the bottom of it the way that
things are currently set up no but then
Ordinary People are not really they
don't really have the capability the
resources to kind of sift through the
information
who does you know look we couldn't in
the process of writing Matt's book you
know Matt and I didn't have the
resources to go through 2.3 million
messages you know that is not any kind
of small undertaking it took Telegraph
eight people full time two months to go
through it all cross-refing it with
graphs and what's in the public domain
and so on shoes operation well you think
that's a tiny fraction of the overall
covered evidence you know how are we
supposed to approach this and yet and
yet it is so important that some attempt
is made so pair it back give it a
realistic time frame and get on with it
and stop hiring masses of lawyers to
protect vested interests these lawyers
are on contracts the last five years or
more that gives you some indication of
how long we're going to be here yeah can
we do the podcast again when it's
um
because there's a there's a lot of
people who are very upset and very angry
with him quite rightly so in my opinion
but he's still a human being I think
that you know there's a lot of people
who dress him up as a villain of the
piece I'm thinking uncaring narcissistic
I don't think he's a monster any more
than I'm a monster
um I think he's highly capable highly
intelligent I found him really good to
work with by and large very very good
manager
um
phenomenally hard working and I love
working with clever people you know he's
a very very able person
um so that's those are the good things
that I want to say I don't know
you're the politician now
that's it it's not yet
fair enough that sounds like damming
with Fame praise I I don't I never
wanted this to be about Matt Hancock as
a bad guy it is so much bigger than that
isn't it and it's not about me being the
good guy or the bad guy either although
there's been a lot of that but really
guys it isn't about me and it isn't
about him look at the material and make
your mind up as to whether on balance we
are better off knowing it I believe
overwhelmingly that we are and it's as
simple as that you've made me feel
somewhat sorry for him actually because
I'm sitting here thinking well what if
the release Boris Johnson's messages I
imagine there's some some good stuff in
there to be honest you better mate yeah
so so it's you you we've got like a
little tiny window into this bigger
picture and Matt Hancock yeah you know
he was at the center of course to a
large extent but still and you mentioned
your own role in this and the way that
you've been in the spotlight which I
have to say maybe I'm probably naive and
stupid but has surprised me
the way people have come after you
because I mean whatever people may think
about you or my Hancock I mean this is
clearly in the public interest is it not
I mean where's that I mean I think it's
absolutely laughable to suggest that it
isn't it's just laughable how can you
possibly suggest that we should not know
how these profoundly important decisions
were being taken of course we should
know that so why why is I mean I mean
Kathy Newman I've got a lot of things to
say on but I won't please do
what's I said it on Twitter it's true
it's her only discernible Talent is to
ask her relevant questions with a
straight face and pretend like that
she's doing something means she didn't
have a street face she had a face that
was all about showbooting and trying to
look clever versus me you know and
trying to make me look bad but anyway
what's what a lot of journalists trying
to do with you is to say you know you
work for talk TV why did you publish
with the telegraph it's for money it's
for this it's for attention and look
Francis and I having this discussion
earlier today when we were sort of
discussing how to handle the interview
and apps and I was sort of saying I
don't really care what your motivation
is for releasing this information
because the information is important if
you did it for money or for attention I
don't care yeah and also people's
people's motivations are complex people
can be interested in the thing and
themselves at the same time and that's
how life Works usually sure I mean I
think my motivations are pretty obvious
I mean it was a vocal critic of lockdown
policy not from day one because I you
know we were talking earlier about the
fact that I that I think most of us went
along with the first initial lockdown
whatever it was three weeks to flatten
the sombrero whatever it was we were
told
um but beyond that I was a very vocal
critic of it all
um so what could be more important if
you're a journalist than getting to the
truth of matters that are that matter to
you and to huge numbers of people it's
not some Niche thing worrying about how
we responded to the pandemic it's
something that affects every single
person to this day in different ways so
you know my motivation working with Matt
Hancock in the first place was to get as
close to the truth as I could what
better way than to work with him on his
project as it happened I got rather more
information than I expected and In
fairness to him he and I've said this
many a time he did lean towards
disclosure not everything I mean you
know he's it was his book after all it
was his truth but I didn't find him
trying to deliberately you know to
trying to cover up a load of stuff that
that he didn't want me to say you get
the sense you feel sorry for him
oh wow that's an interesting question no
I don't feel sorry for him and I'm
certain he won't feel sorry for me no I
don't imagine you will but yeah no but I
want to be really fair here and
acknowledge the pressure that he was on
to acknowledge the enormous sacrifices
that he made and you know he or his
allies listening to this will probably
say how nauseating she's sitting there
saying that having blown him up um but
you were asking me if I feel sorry for
him no but I want to acknowledge that he
is a person and he's he worked really
really really bloody hard and he paid a
very high price personal price Francis
before you jump in I should just say
we'll do another 5-10 minutes of chat
and then send in your questions super
chats paypals and we'll uh pick a bunch
and ask us about a few of them after the
break in about five ten minutes go for a
minute
do you think we have learned our lessons
from kovid or as there will be another
pandemic are we doomed to make the same
mistakes all over again
I do really worry
about what you pointed out earlier which
is a number of people who still want to
be locked down
worries too
that if another pandemic comes and it
really is an absolute horror disease not
that covered wasn't for some people I
really have to emphasize I've never said
this isn't a hideous virus and I was
quite scared of it at the beginning but
the worry is let's say we get something
which is as deadly to people of all ages
as for example Ebola the worry now is
that people will feel that they were
duped by this government and they were
about a number of things they will feel
that they were laughed at and mocked and
that the those making those decisions
were not following themselves which we
know from so-called partygate affair
and they will not go along with it next
time
um so that's the worst case scenario the
best case scenario is something
hopefully we don't get any more of these
but that's probably not realistic there
is if there is another in a dreadful
event there is another pandemic people
this time and I don't mean those who
aren't in a position to do anything
about it but those of us that have
positions in which we can hold a
government to account will ask more
searching questions and the politicians
around them our elected representatives
will not allow power to be seized by a
small group of people who continually
awarded themselves more extensions of
power and that our elected
representatives put up more of a fight
or a challenge to things that they feel
aren't quite substantiated this is one
of the frustrations for me was the way
protesters were treated in completely
different ways so you had the BLM
protest which happened during lockdown
yeah and that happened and everyone
seemed to be fine with it yeah and then
you had anti-lockdown protesters and
there's obviously you know completely
abhorrent wasn't it and not to be
accepted and the police should be
dispatched forth with
um yeah look it was ever lost double
standard Isabel on the BLM I mean
has that already been released because I
haven't seen those
because there's been a lot of coverage
um I think that there may still be some
stuff to come on that area well I was
going to ask you about this because I
have to say look whatever you think of
BLM and people know what I think about
that organization that's fine right
people can be Pro Auntie whatever
that for many people that I know was the
moment when they went hold on a minute
yeah we've just been locked in the
houses for three months yeah and now
because there is a good cause and you
can believe it's a good cause that's
fine yeah people are allowed to protest
in their thousands no mosques no social
distancing in the Streets of London
despite the lockdown that we still have
in place yeah what do we what did we
learn from your Revelations about that
moment what were they saying what was
the conversation like
well you're now testing me because
contacts you remember okay there's so
much stuff
um you know in in this volume of
material which is sort of several sizes
times the size of the Bible
um it wasn't an area that I that Matt
and I focused on in his book but what I
do remember very clearly uh was the
health secretary pushing the cabinet
office to go further in terms of uh not
allowing public protests and I think it
ended up that you know maybe six people
could kind of go along at very socially
distance intervals and make their their
feelings known I mean I thought this was
one of the most shocking aspects of the
whole response the pandemic if we lose
our fundamental right to protest sorry
how are we any better than the worst of
the dictatorships I mean that that seems
to me if if ordinary people cannot
gather on a street or Outsider a
politician's place of work and actually
make their feelings known in the most
direct and peaceful manner that we've
always been allowed to do throughout
modern history
we've lost pretty much everything
haven't we well there were a number of
cabinet ministers and government
advisors who quite approved of the way
China did things let's be blue to be
honest about it so yes there were I mean
here's looking at you Jeremy Hunt you
know the chancellor now
um was one of the main people behind the
scenes who was kind of pushing for a
aspects of the very Sinister Chinese
response I mean I personally felt
mandatory Hotel quarantine for which
people were charged an absolutely
disgraceful amount was a boring thing
and you know the government had to
create very special laws in order to be
able to do that you know to force people
into that type of accommodation into you
know single rooms in which they were
kept for a week or two weeks or whatever
it was and charged an absolute Fortune
for the benefit I don't understand why
anyone ever got themselves into a
situation where they actually went into
that mandatory Hotel quarantine at
places like Heathrow and Gatwick but you
can only imagine that they must have
been in Dreadful circumstances for that
to be upon them and also as well the
Glee with some of the jokes that were
shared on the WhatsApp but the fact that
these people had to pay such massive
sums of money and remember it wasn't
just that that people were fleeced on
because I think they were fleeced they
were fleeced on all these absurd
repetitive covert tests you know you
have to have a package that hideous word
you know making it sounds if you're
getting something good and for your huge
amount of you know massive profit margin
for the companies involved you know the
profit margins on those mandatory covert
tests were grotesque they were you know
you go to other countries and they would
give it to you for virtually nothing
have it processed in no time whatsoever
and off you are off you go on your way
here you're to pay 90 pounds for the
benefit of something's telling you you
were perfectly well as you likely knew
you were to begin with time and again a
covert test before you left a covert
test after you left another one three
days in you know honestly absolute
racket Isabel and let me ask you a party
political question because you describe
yourself early as a right of Center
journalist this was done by a
Conservative Party
conservatives supposed to not want the
government to interfere in people's
lives too much and just let them crack
on with it pretty disillusioning right
well so where does that leave people
like you
well I've never been a member of any
political party I think I'm a small C
conservative I'm not far right as some
people like to claim you laugh but
honestly you know had an article this
morning that was absolutely outrageously
defamatory I had to get that taken down
describing me as a fascist
um yeah I don't even believe in capital
punishment I'm completely liberal on
some of these issues
um where does it leave us I think it
leaves us pretty despairing actually
um I I don't really want to get into
Party politics but since you asked I'd
have to say the Reform Party run by my
partner Richard Tyson is the only party
that consistently opposed lockdown
uh well on that happy note uh why don't
we have a quick break get some questions
from our audience and we'll uh put them
to you uh in about five minutes guys so
send them in send them the super chance
paypals Anton will collect them and
we'll get them together and ask a few of
them before racking up Isabel thank you
so much
see you in five minutes guys
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we share an intimate moment as we watch
a Japanese tourists get trapped in a
tube door
but I wasn't talking about their locals
I was talking about our community on
locals you mean the one where you get
phenomenal behind-the-scenes content
when you thank you
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson we're at Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew door's
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share memes have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
and I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousand of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
hey Francis what is the best way to
advertise a business oh that's easy all
you need to do is spend tons of cash on
a radio advert that advert is guaranteed
to be heard by people who are completely
disengaged and not even properly
listening then simply sit back and watch
all your hard-earned money go up in
Flames what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on [__] FM for the measly
sum of 30 000 pounds and generate
precisely zero sales because
trigonometry now has nearly a million
subscribers across all Platforms in
January alone we generated over 12 and a
half million views and downloads that's
right you can buy an ad with us and
we'll promote your business on one of
our incredible episodes we'll match your
brand with the most suitable episode
that way you know it has every chance of
being a success plus your advert will be
ridden by two professional comedians
that's right we're hiring two
professional comedians we pride
ourselves on making our ads funny and
engaging to the point some people say
they're their favorite part of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate yeah you're right all you need to
do is contact us on marketing at
triggerpod dot Co dot UK that's
marketing add
triggerpod.co.uk advertise with us and
we will get your business noticed by the
most problematic people on planet Earth
Hello everybody welcome back thank you
for submitting your questions we're
going to put them to Isabelle and then
of course I will record a couple of
bonus questions for those of you who are
on locals you've already submitted your
questions there we'll do those
afterwards but for now Francis take it
away absolutely so the first question is
from DC thank you very much DC and they
asks and they ask how do we ensure the
fourth estate flourishes it in the
future it is in Decline with social
media print Journal print journalism is
declining big Tech supports governments
to avoid regulation regulation and run
social media it's a really good question
and for me you know I've been in print
media for a really long time since the
late 90s and I've watched investitive
journalism in particular really Decline
and the reason for that is because it's
highly resource intensive and often you
know if you are
um doing a kind of covert operation it's
very very expensive you know you and you
it saps up resources for an uncertain
outcome you know there was a possibility
for example with the telegraph
investigation that the company could
have put eight weeks of eight of its
best reporters working full time on this
project only for something completely
out of the company's control the news
organization's control to derail the
investigation so that it didn't get
published whether it was a successful
injunction by the government now that's
not totally out of the control of a
newspaper because you can make damn sure
that you've got grounds for that not to
happen but you know who knows what could
have happened there could have been War
breaking out somewhere or all sorts of
things in which case the investment that
a paper makes has been completely
obliterated so very diminishing number
of organizations have these resources
where the traditional papers have lost
those resources we see other
organizations springing up doing their
own kinds of Investigations often those
may have some kind of political agenda
um and you know you can argue about
whether it is a good or a good a good or
a bad thing that those investigations
come out because they may be biased but
what has been heartening about this
operation that I've been involved in is
that there are still traditional papers
like the telegraph the Sunday Times Two
have to say that we'll put big resources
into
investigations in the overwhelming
public interest so all hope isn't gone
but people need to continue buying
newspaper papers or newspaper
subscriptions otherwise it does just
narrow down to smaller organizations
which are not kind of
um so easily so easily scrutinized in
terms of who funds them and what their
agenda may be and to be fair to the
guardian they did some great work
exposing Michelle moan I have no
interest in being fair to the Gods
however with the Fiverr is very
interested in being fair to you and he
says please tell Isabel she's done a
vital service for the country in
releasing these messages and thank you
thank you now
um
yes this is a good question from someone
whose name I will not read that it says
does Isabelle have more messages that
haven't been released yet and we were
talking in the break that there are
going to be further yeah so we've got
some days left of this investigation
um I've also faced quite a few questions
that have come through my Twitter and
all my website as to why we don't just
release them all
um and there's a really good reason for
that and that is because they're full of
private information that isn't in the
public interest I mean most of it by the
way is is pretty trivial really trivial
actually but it wouldn't be right to
Chuck out there a load of civil servants
names and addresses and telephone
numbers and you know who they're going
on a date with and what they thought of
so and so you know the telegraph has
been meticulous at all times in their
public interest threshold for inclusion
of material and that feels like the
right thing to do shoving it all out
there on the internet like some kind of
you know I don't know irresponsible
whistleblower it doesn't feel right to
me um Marky Mark asks a question
scientists about it politics politicians
are mostly terrible at scientists at
science sorry journalists are mostly
awful science we're very bad at maths as
well I've just noticed that over the
years so how do we provide any credible
form of narrative with that being the
case
hmm good question and how are
journalists not taken advantage of by
clever scientists and other clever
people because I in some ways I think
um that is part of the is and was part
of the problem you know in those Lobby
briefings during the pandemic where we
had Chris witty very eminent hugely
knowledgeable uh talking to a bunch of
journalists like myself that don't have
the knowledge you know specialized
knowledge to come back
um that is that is there's a sort of
inbuilt flaw to that a structural floor
I suppose I mean what what you could say
in the context of a pandemic I think
that there needs to be
um a much sort of
more carefully constructed group of
advisors it's not for journalists who
are never going to make us all
scientific experts but I think what went
wrong one of the key things that went
wrong during the pandemic and this is on
Matt Hancock and the people around him
was the suppression of information and
the smearing of dissenters including
scientists by the way
Etc I'm sorry I really think that was
grotesque you know these people that
came up with an alternative way of
dealing with the virus should have been
respected they should have been listened
to they were very very distinguished
figures that led that so-called
Barrington declaration the kind of
prospectus for how things could be done
differently and they were utterly
vilified and the government used every
tool it had to vilify and discredit and
undermine those people and those people
paid a really high pricing career terms
in personal terms I think that that was
appalling disgraceful shameful and it
should never happen again I agree this
is a weird question from Nick so feel
free to ignore it he says Matt Hancock
just didn't they recently did an
interview with Good Morning Britain
where he repeatedly posited that there
would be another pandemic yeah do you
know why he's sort of persuaded about
that I think what you're the person
who's asked that question is getting at
is does he have some secret knowledge
yeah that another pandemic is coming
right and I I don't know if he has any
secret knowledge but I'm going to say
almost certainly not
um I think that what he is saying is
that the way our world is now so very
interconnected with so much Global
movement at all times that it's highly
likely that there will be some other
virus or something else that is like
covid hopefully not a lot worse but
you'd be a fool to sit here and say well
I don't think that's going to happen
again which is why
I said it's just a bit of flu everyone
needs to calm down well I think a lot of
people said that
um so and this is a really interesting
question from Mr Stephen he says Isabel
thank you very much for how long roughly
will the paper the telegraph be
published in the lockdown files in
brackets I need to budget I love that
um we all need to punch it
um budget time apart from anything else
I think it's really important with any
newspaper kind of exposey like this that
you don't Vlog it forever
um you know you've got to quit while
you're ahead you've got to know when's
the time that you've you know you've
made the case
and the telegraph was not trying to make
the case probably I was a bit but the
telegraph is just about putting the
information out there
um but you don't want to to kind of
squeeze it for every pip I don't think
you've got to maintain in any
journalistic Endeavor
um you know your quality so I think the
paper will keep running it for as long
as as the paper thinks that there is
material there that is in very strong
public interest and after that you know
sometimes stories as we've already seen
they have a life of their own you know
it depends where the politics of this
goes it depends whether could there for
example be any kind of prosecutions I'm
not saying that there should be but
there are certainly plenty of people who
still want accountability for what
happened I don't personally feel the
need for you know for blood I don't feel
I don't feel that it gets us anywhere
but I do understand the visceral kind of
anger amongst people who suffered so
profound and perhaps people who's who
were forced to say goodbye to loved ones
over iPads I mean this this is just just
beyond and we have many people write in
to make that very point you know when
you have an audience of people who can
write directly and yeah you hear a lot
of stories yeah and those are the
stories that have come to me yeah yeah
and these policies had a real impact on
people so you can understand why they're
angry and I do agree with you going out
for blood is not what we want but what I
think people do want is as we talked
about earlier making sure this never
happens again in the same way and that's
what I want you know if people ask do I
have an agenda yes my agenda is that
never again does our country and I do
hope no other country does it either go
down this route in such a an
ill-informed cat candid and at times
deeply sinister fashion
well we'll ask a couple more and then we
will wrap up uh June hope uh says is
there anything that you'll be releasing
again this may be testing your memory
after a long couple of weeks uh anything
about the sacking of uh carers who
refuse to uh to get vaccinated uh
there's some forty thousand yeah really
good question I mean I know that there
is material in the whatsapps about that
about whether or not that policy would
be sustainable in fact very early on in
the messages and this is actually in
Matt's book so I can talk about it quite
freely
um you know he puts on records that he
actually believes it should be mandatory
to have the flu jab if you work in the
NHS
um and he was saying that you know he
had hopes to make to implement that
policy had it not been for the
coronavirus coming in and you know
obviously distracting him with a much
bigger problem so you know that's what
he wanted to do it might still happen
under another leader who well another
leader of the Health Service who felt
the same way I remember that there are
conversations about whether or not it
was a good idea and whether or not
essentially they could get away with
doing it and certainly the words get
away with it are not used that's me
paraphrasing it that was a big call you
know to attempt to mandate vaccination
um Matt Hancock had no qualms about that
he vociferous vociferously defended that
as a policy he always argued that if you
are putting yourself into a setting
where people are vulnerable then the
very least you can do is is make sure
that you're not unwittingly making them
sicker and more unhealthy I happen to
profoundly disagree with that I think
it's that it crosses a line for me and
the policy was a disaster and they had
to abandon it it was
courageous guest great interview best
channel on Earth
do you think uh it's just a it's just a
friendly comment to say thank you but
lady sarcastro did ask a question which
is so far we've heard about go Hancock
in case does Isabel think there will be
more people being exposed as complicit
in she says lying but let's say
deceiving the public just to not get
sued
yeah really good question
um I mean you know we there was a sort
of um question mark at the beginning of
this operation about whether you could
cover the stories on a kind of person by
person basis because that's how the
whatsapps came to me you know under
names of individuals uh but actually I
think doing it thematically has worked
really really well uh and I I don't
quite know how to answer that question
but if if the the questioner is asking
are there more people who are we're
about to expose have done truly Dreadful
things then I think broadly the answer
to that is probably no okay it's about
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
so much for coming on the show if people
want to find out more about you and your
work what is the best place to do that
well there is a website
um and also I I did check my Wikipedia
and was wanting to update it and found
that it's now so many people have tried
to do good and bad things to my
Wikipedia patients it's now protected
which means that only moderate can
change it so go to my website
isabellookshot.co.uk fantastic stuff
thanks for coming on we're going to ask
you a couple of questions that go behind
a paywall but for now thank you and
thank you guys for watching and
listening join our locals if you want to
hear that bonus content thanks for being
here live with us uh take care and have
yourselves a great morning evening or
afternoon wherever you are and remember
if you want your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we share an intimate moment as we watch
a Japanese tourists get trapped in a
tube door
but I wasn't talking about their locals
I was talking about our community on
locals you mean the one where you get
phenomenal behind the scenes content
when you the ideal space
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson we're at Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get
brutal behind the scenes footage of our
trip to America where we met a whole
host of incredible guests and gave
ourselves terminal indigestion we're
also starting to do monthly giveaways
for locals only the first one will be
signed copies of Andrew door's new book
plus you get access to an incredible
community of like-minded people who
share memes have fun conversations and
most importantly you get to make new
friends you can support us with as
little as seven dollars or about five
pounds a month or give us more for the
higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
hey Francis what is the best way to
advertise a business oh that's easy all
you need to do is spend tons of cash on
a radio advert that advert is guaranteed
to be heard by people who are completely
disengaged and not even properly
listening then simply sit back and watch
all your hard-earned money go up in
Flames what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on [__] FM for the measly
sum of 30 000 pounds and generate
precisely zero sales because
trigonometry now has nearly a million
subscribers across all Platforms in
January alone we generated over 12 and a
half million views and downloads that's
right you can buy an ad with us and
we'll promote your business on one of
our incredible episodes we'll match your
brand with the most suitable episode
that way you know it has every chance of
being a success plus your advert will be
ridden by two professional comedians
that's right we're hiring two
professional we pride ourselves on
making our ads funny and engaging to the
point that some people say they're their
favorite part of the show yeah we
probably shouldn't admit that mate yeah
you're right all you need to do is
contact us on marketing at triggerpod
dot Co dot UK that's marketing and
triggerpod.co.uk advertise with us and
we will get your business noticed by the
most problematic people on planet Earth